hey everyone welcome back to another
video by simply Lear today we have got
an essential topic for anyone diving
into the world of websites how to create
a website site map whether you're a
season Web Master or a total beginner
understanding s Maps is crucial for
improving your site's visibility on
search engines in this video we will
break down what a Sit map is why it
matters for SEO and most importantly how
you can create one of your own website
stick around because by the end of this
tutorial you will equipped with the
knowledge to enhance your s's
performance just a quick info for you if
you want to upscale yourself master
digital marketing skills and land your
dream job or grow in your career then
you must explore simply learns cohort of
various digital marketing programs
simply learn offers various
certification and post-graduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like SP
Jane Purdue and meta through our courses
you will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like search engine
marketing strategies for paid campaigns
analytics Roi and evaluation and over a
dozen others that's not all you'll also
get the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
working in top D product companies and
academian from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into digital
marketing role as a fresher or moved on
to higher paying job role or profile if
you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comments
and description box to find digital
marketing programs that fits your
experience and areas of interests all
right so let's start with the first one
that is what is a Sit map and why it is
important so sitemap is a file that
contains a list of all the pages on a
website it serves as a road map for
search engines to discover and index the
content on a site having a well
structured site map is important for
several reasons firstly it helps search
engines understand the organization of
your site and prioritize the indexing of
important Pages this can improve the
visibility of your content in search
engine results secondly a sitemap can
also benefit the user experience by
providing an easy way for visitors to
navigate through the site and find the
information they are looking for in
essence a Sit map is like guide that
helps both search engines and visitors
navigate and understand the content of
your website making it an essential tool
for Effective online presence and
visibility so now let's have a look how
it actually looks this is google.com
here let's say We'll type
indianexpress this is a News website
we'll click on it we'll open the website
all right so as we can see this is an
News website the Indian Express all
right so now if we want to have a look
at its sit map sit map all we have to do
is to click on this and slash
sitemap.xml
so now this part is called domain so
website domain serves as the address for
a site on the internet like example.com
the/ site. XML is a specific path where
a sitemap file is stood now the sitemap
and example file details the structure
and relationships between pages on a
website when a search engine encounters
the/ sitemap.xml extension it fetches
the associated file enabling efficient
indexing and understanding of sites
content this benefits search engine
optimization that is SEO by enhancing
the visibility of the website in search
results organizing the content for
search engines and facilitating
streamlined crawling and indexing
processes all right so now by writing
this we can click enter and as you can
see the XML file now we will be having a
look at the documentary as you can see
this is the XML file so this is
basically a XML sit map for this Indian
Express website what is this XML sitemap
so uh think of an XML sitemap as a
website road map for search engines it's
like a cheat sheet that tells search
engines all about your web pages when
they were last updated how important
they are and where to find them like
this helps search engines explore your
sites more efficiently like a GPS for
websites by having this map your site
has a better chance of showing up in
search results because search engines
can easily understand and organize your
content so it's like giving your website
a VIP pass to be noticed and ranked
higher in the online world so this is
what XML sitemap is now if you want to
have a look at HTML sit map then all we
have to do is instead of XML we'll write
HTML so as you can see here this is the
HTML format this is a simple and easy to
understand format so that everyone can
easily understand and go through the
entire website what all links are there
so this HTML sitemap is basically a
userfriendly guide for visitors like
exploring your website instead of
technical details for search engines
it's up page on your site that list all
the important links and sections in a
clear organized way imagine it is a
visual map visitor can easily follow to
find what they are looking for a
simplified navigation tool when you have
this /sit map. HTML page it's usually
accessible to users enhancing their
experience by providing a quick overview
of your website structure it's like
having a directory at entrance of a mall
making it easy for everyone to find the
desired destination so it's basically
that now the question is how to create a
website's sitemap all right so for that
all we have to do is to just open a
website copy the link and we'll have to
paste it at www.
XML sit
maps.com all right so as you can see
this is xmls sitem maps.com site is an
official website now all we have to do
is we have to paste the URL over here
all right now online generator Pro
sitemap PHP script we can ignore this
one and we can click on this start so
this site basically scans the website
scans the pages of the websites and
create an XML file for you so it depends
on the size of the website how much time
it will take now that XML file will have
to upload that XML file to the root
folder so what we are doing is we are
basically creating the XML sitemap file
and we are downloading it and then we'll
upload it to the root folder after
uploading to the root folder we'll paste
the link on the Google search console so
basically to create an XML sitemap file
we use a sitemap generator tool or
Plugin once generated download the file
and upload it to the root folder of your
website using a FTP client or file
manager after uploading access Google
search console navigate to the sitemap
section
and paste the link of the sitemap file
this allows Google to easily discover
and index all the pages on a website
improving its visibility in search
results the third step would be submit
your sit map now that your sit map has
been created and added to your site
files it's time to submit them to search
engines to submit and verify your
websites with Google you'll need to use
the web master tool a cloud-based
software designed specifically for
website owners by Google this tool acts
as a gate gway for submitting your
website to Google search engine it's
worth noting that web master tool has
different versions so you have the
flexibility to choose the one that best
suits you needs even if you prefer the
older version it's still accessible for
your use this allows website owners to
manage and optimize their websites
effectively for search engine visibility
now to verify the website start by
visiting the web master tool so first
step is start by visiting the web master
tool next select add property located in
the top left corner all right proceed to
your input your sites URL all right
after submitting once the scanning
process is complete you will receive
options for verifying ownership of the
domain to complete the verification the
web master tool will generate an HTML
file download this file now head to your
web host and access the C panel file
manager navigate to your domain name
file directory all right after
navigating to the domain name ensure
file is uploaded to the root directory
of your domain once the upload is
finished return to the web master tool
and click on verify option Google will
automatically search for the file on
your website once the HTML file is
detected within your domain your domain
name will be successfully verified now
let's talk about the Google search
console in the Google search console
once you're on the search console Dash
board navigate to crawl sit maps all
right select the ADD test sitemap option
located in the top right corner on the
screen this provides an opportunity to
re-evaluate your sit map for potential
errors before proceeding naturally any
identified mistakes should be corrected
once your sit map is error free proceed
to click on submit and you are done so
in conclusion leveraging XML sit Maps
whether with the tools like XML sit
maps.com or for others is a strategic
choice these digital road maps enhance
SEO streamline navigation and ensure
your website's content shines in the
crowded online realm Embrace this
powerful tool to elevate your online
presence and Captivate both search
engines and users alike all right guys
with that we have come to the end of
this video If you like this video please
give it a thumbs up I hope it really
help you all thanks for watching stay
safe and keep learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations
and delivered by industry experts choose
any of our programs and set yourself on
the path to Career Success click the
link in the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nert up and get certified
click
here